all things are about to get fancy
there's a new retro modern burlesque
show schooling audiences rocky is live
with the charming women of ladylike hi
rocky
hello jillian yeah things are about to
get fancy up in here okay so i'm with
the ladies of ladylike the co-creators
here jamie and summer so let's start
with you jamie what is the definition
the true definition of ladylike i would
say a high class sophistication a strong
woman that knows how to get the job done
but also to get the full definition you
should come check out the show oh okay i
see what you did there i see what you
did there now summer i want to point
this out summer your name is summer
soltis
i thought it was solstice so if it says
solstice on the screen
it's a great name it's so cool okay so
what's the inspiration behind ladylike
and where did this concept come from um
well it's actually a retro modern
burlesque so we took it a spin off of
like a woman's role in the 50s and 60s
so there's a little bit of that style in
it you'll find a little a few of the
songs from the 50s and 60s and then we
wrapped in today's modern style uh with
some amazing choreography and and
up-to-date tunes wow okay so what are
the up-to-date tunes what are some of
the songs that we're hearing when we
when we watch the show and i see i hear
video we're showing the show right now
we've got some erica badou hotline bling
we've got um let's see some lizzo up in
there some lady bree some stella coal so
really fun stuff but all with a twist of
the retro to bring back that vintage
glam i love that and vintage glam but
also that really smart comedy right
explain that summer yeah we mix in
definitely uh we are tongue-in-cheek but
there's really smart written
comedy in there for everybody so a
little bit a little something for
everyone okay so when everyone comes
down to the show to see this here at the
mosaic
what are they going to leave with what's
the what's the feeling what's the vibe
what's the message what's the
empowerment i think they're going to
leave inspired i think they're going to
leave empowered i think they're going to
be like wow i didn't know what i was
coming to see but i took away something
really cool and they haven't seen it yet
so that's right and you guys just
started how was your first couple shows
so far amazing the crowds are amazing
the response is great uh our girls are
amazing our team so couldn't be happier
it's great wow it's beautiful and of
course the costumes and just it's
beautiful in here i love the vintage
chic but the modern twist um you know
what's the when people come down should
they be dressing a certain type of way
what's the
vibe for the audience it seems like
people are picking up on the pastels so
feel free to rock it you don't have to
by any means but yeah come join the club
i think i joined the club today
i think you look great the lady light
club today and that means
i officially have to enroll into charm
school so coming up later in the show
i'm going to get a i'm going to get some
lessons from those beautiful ladies i'll
send it back to you i was gonna say
rocky you match the set you gotta get in
there
all right we'll check back in with you
later on in the hour mercedes